davon kann manche band nur träumen eine
front frau die singt und erst noch
kunstfertig zu trommeln versteht
sehr davon extrem coole jagd zum
schlagzeug spielen
zwei die sich offensichtlich anziehen
und inspirieren
roland vögtlin und maria moling zusammen
sind sie beide mit romanischen wurzeln
aber einer musikalisch ziemlich
unterschiedlichen vergangenheit
sie kommt aus den idyllischen dolomiten
mit dem frauen trio ganges und dessen
gefühligen liedern auf ladinisch die
perfekte botschafterin für das südtirol
doch sie wollte luftveränderung er ist
engadiner aus sprung- und steht auf
harte gitarrenklänge
doch mit texten auf romans kommt er
nicht weit übers tal hinaus
was könnte ihnen besseres passieren als
sich über den weg zu laufen
er suchte eine sängerin für sein neues
projekt und hörte sie mit ihrer band
da war es um die beiden geschehen
ein gestalter auftritt die musik ein
gewinnendes destillat aus den talenten
beide so besingen sie nun die tücken der
liebe in weltläufige mensch
müßig zu einer neuen band machen denn
das muss englisch wenn man halt sofort
mit der sprache auch irgendwie hängt
wird oder willst du vorteil ist der
roman ist das besonders auch in der
schweiz seien extrem schwierig ist zum
twitter co mit mit mit der sprache auch
musikalisch ist das projekt ein gewinn
für beide seiten
sie hat in seinem übungsraum den reiz
von gitarren verzerren entdeckt während
er jetzt mehr auf seine weichen seiten
fokussieren kann
so sehr dass du eher zu dir die härtere
sachen geschrieben steht somit ein
ruhiges hobby
weich und raum kleinere clubs oder
größere seen memory finden ihr publikum
mit ihren fein austarierten songs
und wenn ab und zu mal das temperament
bei meinen durchbricht gleich der andere
aus
wenn man sonst
zehn minuten klar was da passiert und
jeder empfindet das klar wenn man songs
empfinden wir das komplett anders wenn
ich mal schauen was ich für den idee
hält im kopf wie sie das gehört und die
will darüber ein breiterer zum beispiel
unruhig und zogen zwei die aufeinander
hören und zusammen mehr sind als die
summe der einzelteile
danke